ANDERSON STARTS NOW.
>>> GOOD EVENING.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH BREAKING
NEWS ON JUST HOW UNHINGED THE
FINAL DAYS OF THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION WERE AND HOW MUCH
WORSE THEY MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN.
WE HAVE SOME EXAMPLES WHICH ARE
JUST NOW COMING TO LIGHT.
AMERICA'S TOP MILITARY COMMANDER
COMPARING THEN-PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
RHETORIC TO HITLER'S AND HIS
FOLLOWERS TO BROWN SHIRTS, TO
NAZIS.
THAT TOP COMMANDER FOUND HIMSELF
RALLYING SUBORDINATES TO PROTECT
THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
AUTHORITY AND PERHAPS TO HEAD
OFF A COUP.
THESE AND OTHER CHILLING SCENES
ARE CONTAINED IN A NEW BOOK "I
ALONE CAN FIX IT, DONALD J.
TRUMP'S CATASTROPHIC FINAL
YEAR."
THE AUTHORS ARE CAROL LEONNIG
AND PHILIP RUCKER.
IT COMES OUT NEXT WEEK.
CNN HAS OBTAINED A SERIES OF
EXPERTS EACH REALLY MORE
ALARMING THAN THE NEXT.
IN THIS ONE GENERAL MARK MILLY,
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT CHIEFS
OF STAFF IS REASSURING HIS
DEPUTIES ABOUT PREVENTING A COUP
ATTEMPT.
QUOTING NOW FROM THE BOOK.
THEY MAY TRY BUT THEY CAN'T
EFFING SUCCEED, HE TOLD THEM.
WE'RE THE GUYS WITH THE GUNS.
JAMEY DOING THE REPORTING FOR
US, SHE JOINS US NOW.
I MEAN IT'S FASCINATING TO HEAR
HOW FAR GENERAL MILLY AND WHAT
EXACTLY HOW HE SAW THIS.
THERE ARE PARALLELS ACCORDING TO
THE BOOK ABOUT WHAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT SAID ABOUT THE
ELECTION BEING STOLEN AND ADOLPH
HITLER'S RHETORIC.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
MILLY WAS SO SHAKEN BY TRUMP'S
BEHAVIOR THAT WHAT HE DID WAS HE
GOT TOGETHER WITH THE OTHER
CHIEFS, THE NAVY, THE AIR FORCE,
THE MARINES AND THEY PLANNED.
THEY BELIEVED THERE REALLY COULD
BE A COUP ATTEMPT BY TRUMP.
AND LENNING AND RUCKER WRITE
MILLY VIEWS QUOTE, TRUMP AS THE
CLASSIC AUTHORITARIAN LEADER
WITH NOTHING TO LOSE.
AND QUOTED AS SAYING THIS IS A
RIFE STYLE MOMENT, MILLY TOLD
THE AIDES, THE GOSPEL OF THE
FUROR.
WE KNOW PEOPLE WERE CONCERNED
THAT TRUMP WOULDN'T LEAVE
OFFICE.
WE REPORTED THAT.
TO HEAR GENERAL MILLY SAY THIS,
IT'S CLEAR WHEN YOU READ THE
BOOK HE COOPERATED.
THERE ARE EXTENSIVE QUOTES.
>> AND HE COMES OFF LOOKING
PRETTY GOOD FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND.
>> HE DOES.
AND LET'S REMEMBER HE HAD HIS
LAFAYETTE SQUARE VERY BAD
MOMENT.
>> WHICH HE APOLOGIZED FOR.
HE WAS I BELIEVE IN COMBAT
FATIGUES WALKING WITH THE
PRESIDENT IN THAT MOTLEY
ASSORTMENT OF PEOPLE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE TO LAFAYETTE SQUARE.
>> A VERY BIZARRE MOMENT.
BUT TO HEAR GENERAL MILLY SAY
THIS IS STUNNING.
>> THERE WERE ALSO ACCORDING TO
THIS BOOK DAILY CHECK-IN CALLS
THAT MILLY STARTED TO DO WITH
MARK MEADOWS AND SOME OTHERS.
>> ONE OF IT INTERESTING THINGS
ABOUT THAT IS IN THE BOOK MILLY
SAYS HE WAS DOING IT ALSO TO
KEEP TABS ON TRUMP.
AS IF BY TALKING TO POMPEO AND
MARK MEADOWS HE WOULD GET A
BETTER SENSE OF WHAT'S GOING ON.
WE SHOULD SAY THAT POMPEO HAS
DENIED SOME OF THIS ACCOUNT TO
THE AUTHORS.
BUT THERE IS ANOTHER
EXTRAORDINARY MOMENT WHERE AFTER
JANUARY 6th AND MILLY IS SEEING
THE INSURRECTION, HE'S NOW
PREPARING FOR THE INAUGURATION
WITH OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS, WITH THE NATIONAL
GUARD AT FORT MEYER.
AND HE'S SO WORRIED THERE IS
GOING TO BE ANOTHER VIOLENT
ATTACK BY TRUMP SUPPORTERS THAT
HE SAYS TO THE OTHER SENIOR
ADVISERS, QUOTE, HERE'S THE
DEAL, GUYS, THESE GUYS ARE
NAZIS.
THEY'RE PROUD BOYS.
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM WHETHER
YOU'RE A COP, A SOLDIER, WE'RE
GOING TO STOP THESE GUYS TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A PEACEFUL TRANSFER
OF POWER.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT A RING OF
STEEL AROUND THIS CITY, AND THE
NAZIS AREN'T GETTING IN.
>> THAT'S INCREDIBLE TO HEAR.
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF
REVELATIONS INCLUDING ONE AFTER
THE INSURRECTION.
GENERAL MILLY AND CONGRESSWOMAN
LIZ CHENEY IN WHICH CHENEY WHO
VOTED FOR IMPEACHMENT DESCRIBES
THE CONFRONTATION SHE HAD.
IT WAS DURING THE ATTACK, DURING
THE INSURRECTION.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN KIND OF I GUESS -- TELL
US WHAT HAPPENED.
>> SO JIM JORDAN IS A STAUNCH
ALLY OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE'S AT THE HEAD OF THE FREEDOM
CAUCUS.
HE'S KNOWN TO MAKE A CIRCUS OUT
OF THINGS.
HE IS CERTAINLY THE ANTITHESIS
ON THE IMPEACHMENT OF LIZ
CHENEY'S SUPPORT OF THE
IMPEACHMENT.
SO MILLY AND CHENEY ARE ACTUALLY
CLOSE.
THEY'RE FRIENDS.
THEY TALK A LOT.
THEY HAVE A PHONE CALL, AND IN
THE BOOK MILLY SAYS TO CHENEY
THIS IS THE NEXT DAY, THE 7th,
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
AND SHE RECOUNTS THIS ENCOUNTER
WITH JIM JORDAN.
AND SHE SAYS, QUOTE, THAT EFFING
GUY JIM JORDAN, THAT SON OF A --
YOU CAN READ IT ON THE SCREEN --
CHENEY SAID.
WHILE THESE MANIACS ARE GOING
THROUGH THE PLACE I'M STANDING
IN THE AISLE, AND HE SAID WE
NEED TO GET THE LADIES AWAY FROM
THE AISLE.
LET ME HELP YOU.
I SMACKED HIS HAND AWAY AND TOLD
HIM GET AWAY FROM ME.
YOU EFFING DID THIS.
I DON'T THINK LIZ CHENEY FELT
SHE NEEDED JIM JORDAN'S HELP.
>> ACCORDING TO THIS DURING THE
ACTUAL INSURRECTION LIZ CHENEY
SAW THIS AS A DIRECT RESULT OF
JIM JORDAN AND THE OTHER
ENABLERS OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LOOKING BACK WE KNEW ABOUT THE
BIG LIE.
AND JIM JORDAN WAS CLOSE TO THE
PRESIDENT.
HE WAS PROBABLY CALLING THE
PRESIDENT EVERY DAY, A COUPLE OF
TIMES A WEEK IN THE WEEKS
LEADING UP TO JANUARY 6th.
IT WAS NOT A SURPRISE TO LIZ
CHENEY THAT THIS HAPPENED, AND
SHE FEELS THAT JIM JORDAN WAS
PART OF IT.
>> I WANT TO BRING IN ALSO WITH
US -- STAY WITH US BECAUSE I
WANT TO BRING IN OUR CHIEF
CORRESPONDENT DANA BASH ALSO A
CNN LAW ENFORCEMENT ANALYST AND
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE.
SO DANA, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CONCERNS FROM THE COUNTRY'S TOP
MILITARY OFFICER OF AN ATTEMPTED
COUP BY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND HIS ALLIES.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS YOU
HAVE TO KIND OF STEP BACK AND
JUST KIND OF REALIZE THIS IS SO
OUT OF THE ORDINARY.
THERE WERE CLEARLY A LOT OF, YOU
KNOW -- A LOT WORSE THINGS
HAPPENING BEHIND THE SCENES
ACCORDING TO THIS THAN ANYONE
KNEW PUBLICLY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT IS IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND AND LEARN THIS FOR
LOTS OF REASONS.
BUT FIRST AND FOREMOST IT'S
BECAUSE, YES, IT'S HISTORY BUT
IT IS RECENT HISTORY.
AND IT INFORMS WHAT IS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT IS IF GENERAL MILLY
WAS, YOU KNOW, SAYING THESE
THINGS AND SCREAMING FROM THE
ROOFTOPS AND HAVING
CONVERSATIONS, JAMIE'S REPORTING
ALSO ABOUT THIS BOOK IS THAT
NANCY PELOSI, THE HOUSE SPEAKER,
WAS INVOLVED IN CONVERSATIONS.
THEN THERE'S NO WAY THAT THE
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP WEREN'T
ALSO AWARE OF SOME OF THIS EVEN
IF THEY DIDN'T HAVE DIRECT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE LIKES OF
GENERAL MILLY.
THOSE REPUBLICAN LEADERS ARE
CURRENTLY RUNNING THE GOP AND
RUNNING TOWARDS DONALD TRUMP
STILL RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS IF
YOU LOOK AT IT FROM WHERE WE ARE
NOW IS SO REMARKABLE THAT EVEN
THOSE DAYS, THESE STORIES, WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th IN THE
DAYS FOLLOWING, IF THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH FOR THEM TO SAY, WOW, WE
HAVE TO STAND UP AND SEPARATE
OURSELVES FROM HIM IT'S HARD TO
IMAGINE WHAT IS.
>> I JUST WANT TO READ THIS PART
ABOUT THE COUP AGAIN FOR YOUR
REACTION.
MILLY SAYS THEY MAY TRY BUT
THEY'RE NOT KNOWING TO EFFING
SUCCEED.
HE TOLD THEM YOU CAN'T DO THIS
WITHOUT THE MILITARY.
YOU CAN'T DO THIS WITHOUT THE
CIA AND FBI, WE ARE THE GUYS
WITH THE GUNS.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT
OF GUNS OUT THERE IN
CIRCULATION.
BUT THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT
CHIEFS WAS ESSENTIALLY READY FOR
A SHOWDOWN WITH THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF AND COMPARING HIM TO
HITLER.
>> YEAH, HE WAS APPARENTLY.
AND SOUNDS LIKE HE WAS ACTUALLY
THINKING THROUGH THE MECHANICS
OF WHAT A -- A MILITARY
CONFLICT, A HOT CONFLICT WOULD
LOOK LIKE AND HOW THAT WOULD
PLAY OUT HERE IN THE CAPITOL.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY EXTRAORDINARY.
I THINK IT, FORTUNATELY, SHINES
YET ANOTHER LIGHT ON THE
COMMITMENT AND THE DEDICATION OF
CAREER PUBLIC SERVANTS, THIS
TIME OF COURSE GENERAL MILLY AND
HIS TEAM IN THE MILITARY WITH
THE COURAGE TO STAND UP TO
REALIZE THAT SOMETHING WAS GOING
HORRIBLY OFF THE RAILS WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND THAT THEY MIGHT BE THROWN
INTO A TERRIBLE, TERRIBLE NEVER
BEFORE THOUGHT OF OR EXPERIENCED
SCENARIO IN WHICH THEY HAD TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT YOU SUGGESTED,
WHICH IS STAND UP TO THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
BUT THEY WERE WILLING TO DO IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE THOSE SORT OF
DEDICATED, CAREER PROFESSIONALS
SERVING IN GOVERNMENT.
>> ALSO IT MAKES YOU THINK ABOUT
ALL THOSE PEOPLE WHO TOOK PART
IN THE INSURRECTION, WHO
ATTACKED THE CAPITOL WHO CALLED
THEMSELVES PATRIOTS, AND THAT
WORD PATRIOT HAS NOW BEEN TAKEN
OVER BY FAR-RIGHT -- YOU KNOW,
THERE WERE FAR-RIGHT
NATIONALISTS WHO MARCHED I THINK
IT WAS THROUGH PHILADELPHIA THE
OTHER DAY CALLING THEMSELVES
PATRIOTS.
YOU READ WHAT MILLY WAS DOING,
AND WHICH, YOU KNOW, IS OBEYING
THE CONSTITUTION.
IT'S STANDING UP TO THE OATH
THAT HE AND SERVING MEMBERS HAVE
TAKEN.
I MEAN THAT'S WHAT A PATRIOT
DOES.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT,
ANDERSON.
IT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
SO PATRIOT IS SOMEONE WHO STAYS
COMMITTED TO THAT OATH, TO
CONSTITUTION DESPITE THE
POLITICS AND THE CRAZINESS
SWIRLING AROUND THEM.
IT DOES THE RIGHT THING FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE OBEYING THE LAW
UNLIKE THE DIRECTION THEY WERE
BEING PUSHED BY THE PRESIDENCY
OF THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY STUNNING,
AND WAY THAT CROWD THAT ATTACKED
OUR CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th HAS
COMPLETELY CO-OPTED THE
SYMBOLOGY AND TERMINOLOGY OF
PATRIOTISM SHOULD BE AN OFFENSE
TO A